يستعرض خفه ظله مستذكرا نكته كانت قد
استخفت بكبر سنه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
وكانه في هذا المشهد يخرج من فيلم سينمائي
[تصفيق]
تشق الضحكه فمه وتاره ترسم الابتسامه على
شفاه الجمهور خلال حفل عشاء مراسلي البيت
الابيض بواشنطن استغله بايدن ليتحدث عن
انجازاته خلال فتره ولايته ليتطرق عقبها
الى تعليق ساخر عن طرد المذيع الشهير من
شبكه فوكس نيوز الاخباريه فمن دق الباب
اسمعه بايدن الجواب بفكاهته
[تصفيق]
لدينا الكثير لنفخ به نشرنا اللقاح اصلحنا
الاقتصاد وانتصرنا في الانتخابات النصفيه
ولم ينتهي العمل بعد لكنه انتهى بالنسبه
فتنضرب فيها عصفورين بحجر واحد ففي تكمله
خطابه الذي يبدو وكانه منصه لعرض كوميدي
المح الى اهانه لك هيلي المرشحه الجمهوريه
للرئاسه التي عايرته براسه الذي اشتعل
شيبا فعدى عن وصفها اياه بانه اضعف رئيس
في التاريخ الحديث قالت انه قد لا يعيش
لولايه ثانيه
يتابع بايض النكاته ويصف رابع رئيس
للولايات المتحده بصديقه الصدوق جيمس
ماديسن الملقب بابي الدستور ومنشئ الحزب
الجمهوري
بعد كل ذلك انا اؤمن بالتعديل الاول ليس
فقط لان صديقي العزيز جيمس ماديسون كتبه
تصدق القول ربما فلا تتوا الدعابه
المدروسه تلك ففي حفل العشاء هذا لم يترك
بايدن احدا وشانه للملياردير الامريكي
ايلون ماسك وللر السابق دونالد ترامب ولا
حاكم ولايه فلوريدا والكثير غيرهم اهم من
هذا كله وقف ليقول كلمته 80 ولكن في اوج
عطائي
[موسيقى]
اسراء الصغير العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات